Speaker 1: Okay, let's try instead. We will try.
How about Chris from Texas? Chris from Texas,
welcome to the program. You are on and I
would love to hear what's on your mind today.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. So I
guess one thing I was wondering
is that I guess with the new Pokémon
Games being based out of Liberia,
it always had me interested in now
Latin American culture. Hmm. So
one question I had is like, for example,
how do we define Hispanic and Latino? Is
it by ethnicity or nationality?
Speaker 1: Oh, we you know,
we've looked at this before. There's two different
camps on this issue. There's one camp that says
Hispanic and Latino are two completely different
things. And there's another camp that says this
is more a semantic argument in the modern era
than it is really about differences. And you
can use the terms interchangeably. It depends on
what your perspective is. One view is Hispanic
means of Spanish origin, whereas Latino means
from Latin America, which is basically like,
what's Latin America? I guess Latin America,
the Spanish speaking countries in Central
and South America, like a lot of people
say, Brazil is not really Latin America.
It's I don't know. It's I don't know how
important it is to keep going with that,
because is it is it increasingly just
like a semantic question, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess because I was always
confused because I know you're from Argentina,
right? That's correct. And I know, like
one of the thing I was always confused
about with Argentina's, that it has a large
Italian population, which kind of surprised
me at first when I learned about Argentina.
Yeah, I was going to. But Italians aren't
necessarily like Latino though, or Hispanic.
Speaker 1: Right. Well, that's another thing.
Like, why am I why am I Latino or Hispanic in the
United States? Ethnically, I'm an Ashkenazi Jew.
If my family had moved from Ukraine to the U.S.
rather than from Ukraine to Argentina to the U.S.,
my genetics would be exactly the same.
My my ethnicity would be the same,
but I would not be Hispanic. But per
the way that the census is written,
I'm Hispanic. So I don't know. You know, this
these things are sort of confusing to some degree.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Okay. I understand.
Thanks for the call, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Chris
from Texas, thank you so much.